(dance music)
- Hi, my name is David Dang.
I'm a hairstylist and trichologist.
To have even four men,
come to the shoot today.
To speak about the potential of hair loss
or the subject of hair loss is huge.
(upbeat music)
So, why do you think
that you have hair loss?
- My dad is bald.
my brother's hairline
is worse than LeBron's.
I think I'm next.
- Prior to this, I had a topknot
and then I started to realize
that my hair looked like
it was starting to thin.
- Track alopecia is when
people braid their hair.
It breaks the follicles.
- I feel like, at one point
someone talked about a widow's peak
and if you had that,
then it meant that you
were gonna lose your hair.
And that freaked me out for a minute.
Which, I don't think is true.
- When the guys see
their hairline go back,
a little bit more.
That's natural.
To have your hairline
recede just a little bit.
- My oldest has a little
bit of thinning here.
Because of that, well
maybe I would thin out.
And he started thinning at my age now.
- The general age of someone losing hair,
that I've experienced;
is between the age of 20 to like 30,
maybe even early 30's.
(dramatic music)
As far as I see here, it's perfect.
And if I'm running my hands through it,
it's perfect too.
You have medium to coarse hair
and then your hairline.
The only areas of concern
that I can probably see.
Is a little patch, right here
and that's probably breakage.
I really don't see any areas of concern.
- Okay.
- (laughs)
- Alright, cool.
- Are you okay?
- Yeah, I came in here very worried
that you were gonna be like,
"Look man, this is it.
Six months, get ready."
- (David) Your hairline is healthy,
which is great.
Your natural dreads are awesome.
I don't see a lot of concerns here.
I do see slight concern in the back.
Slight.
- That's what I thought.
- (David) I'm gonna have to prescribe him
some minoxidil.
And minoxidil, basically
is it helps to block
any extra hormones which causes
the hair loss suffocation,
in the derma layers.
(laughs)
I don't really see any areas of concern.
- I'm gonna be thick for days!
- Oh my God!
I can see how you probably
would think in the hairline,
because your hair is fine
and it's lighter.
So, you could see right
through your scalp.
- I feel like this is so important.
Especially, guys don't
talk about beauty much.
We don't do a lot of
accessorizing, typically.
So, this is one of the main features
of our presence.
So, that's why I think
we put so much faith in it
to stay there forever.
Because it's one of the only things we do
to decide how we look.
- So talk about your hair wardrobe.
What does that look like?
- My hair wardrobe?
What do you mean by that?
- Hair wardrobe.
- Like a little tie?
Like little berets?
Little... what are they?
Brats?
- Barrettes?
Brats?!
- I don't know.
Yeah, those little metal fasteners.
(laughter)
Or those dolls with
preposterous proportions.
- Where's the Bratz?